This is a production of Cornell University
The Long Island Horticultural Research and
Extension Center is a 68-acre Cornell University
facility on the eastern end of the island.The mission of our research center is to helpour agricultural community out here
in SuffolkCounty succeed. The main focus is applied research
and education and I think that is something
that really the growers can't get elsewhere
we focus on Long Island soils and microclimates
and being in this maritime climate we are
pretty unique compared to the rest of the state.And that's important to have that research
and education that is directly applicable to our
area. We are an extension of Cornell University. We
are providing you with the information that's done
at Cornell University and also the very applicable
research that's done here at the research lab
and we're extending that out into the community.
I think it's important to have this resource
for growers and landscape professionals for
a number of reasons. Probably the
most important is that there are
day-to-day problems and issues that need to
be solved that can put them out of business.
If a grower is not sustainable, they're not
going to stay in production. So sustainable and
how they're growing things sustainable in their
business are all very important. So I'm looking at
managing plant diseases in the best possible way
-- the most effective way so they're going to have
minimal costs going into control because
they're using the best possible practices.
Implementing sustainable practices, all farmers
want to increase the sustainability of their
operation. All farmers are looking to improve soil
health and have a better crop. At the end of the
day, farms are businesses and sustainability
and longevity is extremely important.
We've changed over time from a philosophy of using
a chemical to stop a problem to using more of a
strategy to stop a problem. We have a program with
orchards where we've introduced mating disruption,
for example. So that can substitute for the use
of pesticides. It also can give you better control
than you would have with with insecticides.
So that's widely been adopted here. It's very
successful. It works quite well. Inside this
tube, there is the same chemicals that female
insects actually release. This pheromone mating
disruption technology is a non-insecticidal
control method and it is organically compatible.
So this is good for the environment. So you don't
have to use any insecticides when you are
using the insect mating disruption ties.
It's important to me that growers understand when
it's too late to make a pesticide application or
when it's important to do something at a certain
time in relation to the crop production cycle,
because then they're not wasting chemicals
that could otherwise just not be put into the
environment. If they're doing the right thing at
the right time then they achieve their objective
and they're not polluting. Soil health
is critical. Soil is a living system and
how we manage it has a direct impact --
not just on farms and in the crops being
grown -- but environmentally downstream. And
with the agriculture stewardship program,
we're focusing on protecting our ground
and surface waters here on Long Island.
We're trying to maintain the aquifer which
is the sole source of our drinking water
as pure as it can be. We need to figure out a way
to manage the weeds even without some of the tools
that other people have. When not only you see your
research and are able to show growers the research
is successful, but they adopt it, that's when you
know you've been you've really made a difference.
Having a place where we have specialists
from entomologists to plant pathologists
to soil scientists and floriculturalists is
so critical. Agriculture is a system and we
all need to collaborate and work together
to be the best resource for our farmers.
This has been a production of Cornell
University, on the web at cornell.edu.